si vous en avez Mar de faire des corvets
à la maison le nettoyage vous sort par
les yeux et vous voulez quelque chose de
très simple une superbe solution bien
justement j'ai aujourd'hui deux
aSPIRATEURS ROBOT que je vais vous
présenter de la marque ecovax on a le
dbot T20 omni et le dbot T20 e omni
alors sont quasiment les mêmes à une
grosse différence très grosse différence
et très grosse nouveauté qu'on retrouve
sur le dibot T20 omni et bien c'est
qu'il vient laver votre sol avec de
l'eau chaude à 55°r ça c'est un très
très gros bénéfice je vais vous
l'expliquer dans quelques instants et
d'ailleurs profitez-en parce que on né
en période de Black Friday et il y a des
tarifs super intéressants pour venir les
acheter dans les meilleures conditions
normalement votre dibot T20 omni coûte
1099 € et du 17 au 27 novembre profitez
de 27 % de remise 27 % de remise c'est
énorme vous le touchez à 799 €. il y a
également une super promo sur le 10bot
t20e omni qui coûte normalement 799 € et
bien là ecovax vous donne 19 % de remise
ça vous tombe à 649 € et ça c'est
valable du 13 jusqu'au 27 novembre pour
ce modèle là profitez-en cliquez vite
sur les liens que vous avez juste en bas
dans la description pour venir acheter
vos aspirateurs robots dans les
meilleures conditions voilà la bête vous
avez la station l'aspirateur qui situe
juste là qui est positionné
tranquillement et qui attend ses
commandes le truc qui est sympa c'est
que d'une c'est joli ça se mélange très
très bien avec ma maison voyez en terme
de teinte de couleur on est bon ça ça
fonctionne votre aspirateur il vient
directement à l'intérieur pour se
recharger et pour se vider le nombre de
bouton est très simple vous avez un
petit bouton sur le dessus si vous
souhaitez l'envoyer travailler il y en a
un ici sur l'aspirateur robot sinon
c'est assez épuré c'est très simple et
assez efficace comme ça personnellement
j'aime beaucoup si on lève le capot de
la station on vient trouver à
l'intérieur deux bacs un bac d'eau
propre vous voyez ici il a bossé il est
quasiment vide on peut le monter
jusqu'ici au maximum alors il faut
savoir qu'on a 4 L en tout de contenance
donc ça c'est le bac d'eau propre qui va
être juste ici vous avez également un
bac d'au sale donc là il a bossé il est
sale 4 l également le truc qui est
génial c'est que lorsque lui travaille
et bien il va venir nettoyer avec de
l'eau chaude à 55°r directement sur vos
sol et ensuite il va remonter l'eau sale
ici vous prenez ensuite votre e sale
vous la videz vous rechargez l'eau
propre c'est très simple c'est pratique
et en plus de ça vous avez en dessous un
petit bouton vous appuyez ça vous ouvre
ici vous avez votre sac à aspirateur là
vous avez 3 l de poussière donc là aussi
vous avez franchement le temps de voir
venir et puis après si besoin pouvez
venir commander des sacs en plus votre
aspirateur robot regardez il se présente
comme ça tout à l'avant vous avez la
partie laser qui va venir cartographier
et comprendre son environnement là
lorsqu'il va toucher un obstacle vous
voyez il y a cette partie là qui va
s'enfoncer dire hop je suis en contact
je suis en contact je suis en contact
comme ça il est informé directement vous
avez également des capteurs sur les
côtés quand on lui lève le capot dessous
on vient retrouver un bouton pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre un bouton pour
le wifi pour faire un reset le petit bac
à poussière qui vient récupérer toutes
les poussières avant de les remonter
directement ici dans votre sac qui est
là donc là voyez c'est super propre sur
le dessous on va venir retrouver ici les
petites balayettes qui vont tourner dans
un sens et dans l'autre pour venir
ramener les cochonneries vers
l'intérieur vous avez cette brosse ici
rotative en caotchou qui va venir les
récupérer avec l'aspiration qui se fait
là ça rentre dedans vous voyez si jamais
il y a un truc un jour qui se coince
vous pouvez venir la prendre la lever
très facilement il y a aucun problème
c'est vraiment très très très simple
d'entretien et de nettoyage donc ça
c'est quand même vachement cool vous
avez ensuite vos petits patins ici qui
viennent tourner pour nettoyer très
facilement et qui viennent sécher ici
directement dans votre station et notez
également qu'à l'arrière vous avez deux
petits connecteurs qui permettent la
recharge pour se recharger au fond de la
station on les voit on les devine là-bas
alors juste avant je vous ai montré le
10bot T20 omni voici le 10bot T20 omni
voyez c'est quasiment la même chose il
se ressemble c'est très compliqué de
pouvoir les différencier comme ça à
l'œil nu vous avez de la même vos
réservoirs d'eau propre et d'eau sal qui
se situe juste ici vous avez de la même
manière votre tiroir avec votre sac
d'aspirateur qui situe juste ici et
votre robot qui est positionné juste en
bas premier point positif lorsque vous
commencez avec votre aspirateur qu'il
arrive à la maison vous l'avez déballé
que vous l'avez installé fait une
cartographie très rapide pas besoin de
galérer le temps qu'il connaissent votre
maison 6 minutes pour venir scanner 100
m² quelque chose près c'est quand même
très rapide très simple ça c'est
vachement bien comme ça après vous
pouvez dire ça c'est la cuisine la salle
à manger ça c'est le salon que saisje
encore les toilettes à vous de voir ce
cachez-vous et bien vous l'envoyez
directement dans la pièce dont vous avez
besoin si vous voulez faire un nettoyage
pièce par pièce et si vous voulez venir
faire un nettoyage global et bien vous
l'envoyez directement après on peut
faire des séquences bref je vous monre
tout ça dans l'application dans quelques
instants parce que oui il y a une app
elle est complète elle est intéressante
elle vous permet de piloter plusieurs
aspirateur robot en même temps alors
rassurez-vous un seul et même aspirateur
robot peut venir faire plusieurs étages
donc si vous avez une maison avec
différents étages pas besoin de mettre
un aspirateur par étage non vous en
prenez un seul vous lui faites scanner
votre premier étage votre rchaussée peu
importe et quand c'est fini vous
pouvezer faire ensuite une nouvelle
carte pour le 2ème étage le 3e le 4e le
5e allez savoir en fonction de votre
maison cette techno c'est le trou
mapping 2.0 c'est une techno que nous
propose ici eovax que je trouve très
efficace autre point positif ici qu'on
VI retrouver avec ses aspirateurs le
dbot T20 omni ou le dbot t20e omni et
bien c'est que vous avez une énorme
puissance d'aspiration on monte ici
jusqu'à 6000 Pascal alors qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire tout ça ça veut dire qu'en
fait si vous avez un animal comme moi la
maison un chien un chat ou que sais-je
encore et qui laisse des poils au sol et
bien votre aspirateur va être en
capacité d'enlever tous les poils de
vraiment venir vous nettoyer en
profondeur et l'autre point positif
c'est que si vous avez un tapis et bien
il va venir nettoyer aussi aspirer en
profondeur sur votre tapis alors il y a
un truc qui est vachement bien vachement
bien au niveau des tapis c'est que vous
le voyez ici vous avez deux petites
brosses qui vont venir tourner très
rapidement c'est pratique pour nettoyage
et bien ces brosses comme elles sont
mouillées on n pas envie qu'elles
viennent frotter votre tapis pour pas
venir salir votre tapis pour pas venir
endommager les brosses non plus et bien
il y a une techno qui est vachement
intéressante et qui mis en place ici
écovax c'est-à-dire que ces deux petites
brosses voyez elles vont remonter de 9
mm lorsqu'elles arrivent sur un tapis ça
veut donc dire qu'ici il y a aucun
frottement avec votre tapis et vous êtes
vraiment tranquille alors rassurez-vous
votre aspirateur robot il est
intelligent il est en capacité de savoir
ce qui est du tapis de ce qui n'est pas
du tapis et en plus de ça il est capable
de détecter les objets grâce au trou
détect 3D 3.0 ça veut dire que lorsqu'il
est en train de passer l'aspirateur chez
vous de nettoyer les sols et qu'il va
tomber sur un jouet de votre enfant sur
un jouet de votre chien si vous avez
laissé traîner une paire de chaussur en
plein milieu et bien il va reconnaître
cet objet il va le contourner il fera le
nettoyage autour mais il va pas venir
bouger tout ça il va pas venir mettre le
bazar chez vous et ça c'est quand même
très très bien donc là mon aspi il est
là je vais lui demander d'aller nettoyer
là mais je luii fait un petit parcours
on va voir s'il le fait bien et vous
allez voir ça va bien se
passer donc là il est en train de
chercher la porte de sortie il se
rapproche il se rapproche et il a trouvé
la porte de sortie voilà comme ça il y
va et il peut faire le nettoyage là-bas
on se parle donc ici dans robot
aspirateur laveur et il y a un autre
truc que fait très très bien cet
aspirateur robot c'est le nettoyage des
angles parce qu'on pourrait se dire ok
il va aller tout droit il va avancer il
va pas venir nettoyer contre une plainte
et ben non parce qu'en fait il y a un
truc qui est très malin c'est que lui il
avance de travers tac il avance il
avance il avance ce qui lui permet c'est
qu'avec cette petitte Boros là sur le
côté et bien de totalement venir
nettoyer les recoins de votre maison
donc ça c'est quand même aussi vachement
bien et puis comme je vous le disais
vous avez deux tampons rotatifs ici qui
vont jusqu'à 180 tours par minute alors
après ça vous pouvez venir choisir dans
l'application peut vraiment venir
paramétrer ça c'est aussi vachement cool
une fois de plus on parle de
l'application dans quelques instants
mais ce qui est bien en fait si vous
voulez c'est que ça vient prendre la
main main comme si vous frottiez vous
avec votre main 180 tours par minute
avec votre main croyez-moi que là vous
frottez vachement fort donc vous prenez
ça avec en plus sur le dbot T20 omni le
fait qu'il viennent nettoyer avec de
l'eau chaude c'est comme si vous vous
preniez une serpilère que vous veniez
frotter vraiment fort avec une eau
chaude à 55°r c'est vachement cool
pourquoi parce que ça va venir éliminer
les graisses donc toutes les taches de
graisses ça va les enlever si vous avez
une tache de café qui est resté au sol
pareil ça l'enlève et en plus de ça ça
vient prévenir des mauvaises odeurs et
vous avez également la possibilité de
rajouter un détergent additionnel ce qui
fait que là vous AZ le combo ultime pour
venir nettoyer votre maison et cette
techno nettoyage s'appelle l'osmo turbo
2.0 donc ici un sol propre bien nettoyé
en profondeur de tous les côtés et alors
vous me direz ok ça c'est bien mignon
monsieur gr mais en fait lorsque ta
petite serpilière patin là est mouillé
au bout d'un moment ça va sentir mauvais
il y a des odeurs qui vont se dégager ma
mes amis pourquoi parce qu'ici eovax ça
pensa à tout en fait la techno qui est
assez intéressante c'est qu'en fait ils
viennent les sécher soit en 2 he soit en
3h soit en 4 He une fois de plus c'est
vous qui avez la main directement dans
l'application séchage à chaud bien
évidemment et là vous voyez là il a
nettoyé hier et ils sont complètement
secs donc ici pas de mauvaise odeur va
mettre leus ça sent le propre ça sent
bon donc ça c'est vachement cool et
cellelà justement se situe la différence
entre le dbot T20 omni et le dbot t20e
omni c'est qu'en fait le dbot T20 omni
lui il va venir nettoyer avec de l'eau
chaude à 55°gr tandis que le dibot t20e
omni lui il va venir nettoyer à l'eau
froide cette technologie de nettoyage à
l'eau chaude à 55°r c'est la première
fois que je le vois sur un aspirateur
robot alors fatalement on comprend il y
a une différence de tarif celui qui ira
le plus loin et qui permettra de mieux
nettoyer en dégraissant davantage c'est
le dbot T20 omni autre point qui est
essentiel et qui est important votre
aspirateur robot il est fourni avec une
station de base C station de base lu
permet de venir se recharger bien
évidemment de venir sécher ces
serpillères ça je vous ai expliqué mais
également de se remplir en eau propre de
vider l'eau sale et de vider la
poussière est-ce qui est vachement bien
en ayant ces réservoirs d'eau et ce sac
à poussière directement intégré dans
votre station c'est que ça vous laisse
jusqu'à 75 jours de tranquillité sans
venir vous toucher vos bac àau ou votre
sac à poussière il y a un autre truc qui
est super important bien évidemment ces
aspirateurs sont compatibles Mazon Alexa
Google assistant mais là où eovax va
plus loin c'est qu'ils fournissent
eux-mêmes leur propre assistant à base
d'intelligence artificielle il s'appelle
i y i K et io vous permettra de faire
pas mal de choses vous l'appelez vous
lui dites ok io et vous lui donnez la
commande vocale que vous voulez et ce
qui vraiment intéressant comparer à ce
qu'on peut retrouver avec Google
assistant ou Amazon Alexa qui fonctionne
bien c'est que vous aurez beaucoup plus
de commandes éligibles et compatible
directement avec l'assistant d'covax ICO
que vous n'en aurez avec l'assistant
d'Amazon ou l'assistant de Google vous
pourrez dire io va nettoyer tel truc va
faire tel truc il en fera davantage donc
ça c'est quand même vachement bien et
beaucoup plus complet et à noter ici en
plus que vous avez une grosse batterie
de
20 mamph qui vous permet de faire le
nettoyage de votre maison quasiment en
une fois alors il retournera
régulièrement à la station pour venir se
recharger en eau propre et vider l'au
sal sortir la poussière mais globalement
ici l'autonomie est très bonne et même
au combien vous auriez une énorme
surface et qu'il aurait besoin de venir
secharger et bien il dirait surcharger
et reprendra son nettoyage là où il l'a
laissé l'application descovax est aussi
bien fichu vous retrouvez ou vos
aspirateurs directement ici voyez moi
j'en ai plusieurs donc là on va
retrouver le t20e omni le dbot T20 omni
vous arrivez directement hop là en
cliquant ici vous rentrez directement
dans votre application là vous voyez vos
informations de votre dernier nettoyage
qui était fait ici alors je suis sur le
rez- de-chaussée vous voyez puis vous
pouvez avir également d'autres cartes
une fois de plus ça dépendra si vous
avez une maison en appartement sur
plusieurs étages ou sur un seul étage ce
qui est très cool c'est tous les modes
de ménage que vous allez trouver ici par
exemple je peux faire un nettoyage
automatique j' appuy sur le bouton bleu
il part directement après vous avez vos
préférences de nettoyage là c'est mode
aspiration plus sa pière vous avez là
vous avez passé l'aspirateur avant la
serpillère c'est quand même plutôt pas
mal à vous de voir une fois de plus ça
dépendra de vous de votre façon de vivre
vous avez le mode serpillère et vous
avez l'aspiration vous pouvez lui dire
nettoyer de passer une fois ou deux fois
s'il y a beaucoup de saleté et puis
après sur la puissance d'aspiration j'ai
standard silencieux max ou alors max
plus ça va tartiner à Max il y a
vraiment beaucoup à spirer c'est très
sale donc vous voyez on peut vraiment
venir le personnaliser ça c'est quand
même super cool vous pouvez l'indiquer
en retour à la station si vous voulez et
puis après vous glissez votre doigt et
vous faites un petit swipe vers le haut
et vous arrivez sur différents modes
efficacité du nettoyage standard en
profondeur ou alors rapide il va passer
rapidement nettoi voyez pour tous les
jours si besoin est et après vous avez
également le nettoyage en profondeur des
coins moi je suis venu le cocher parce
que je trouve ça quand même vachement
important de venir nettoyer dans les
coins c'est souvent là où vient se
mettre la poussière comme ça il y va
vous êtes peénable après vous avez
également la stratégie pour venir
nettoyer les tapis alors moi j'ai mis
l'autoboost pendant l'aspiration c'est
là où il va venir envoyer le max
d'aspiration jusqu'à 6000 Pascal comme
je vous disais tout à l'heure il y a
également l'adaptatif pour les tapis là
où il va venir relever directement les
lingettes vous pouvezuss si vous
souhaitez faire le choix de venir éviter
les tapis ou alors carrément d'ignorer
les tapis moi ce que je vous conseille
c'est l'adaptatif pour les tapis comme
ça vous êtes peinard après ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'avec toutes les
options que vous avez là vous pouvez
faire différents types de nettoyage par
exemple dire le lundi tu vas faire que
les sols et les mardis le tapis pourquoi
pas à vous de voir vous AZ également des
séquences de nettoyage par quelle pièce
tu vas venir commencer d'abord cette
pièce puis celle-là puis celle-l le
nettoyage intelligent c'est plutôt cool
le degré d'humidité de la lingette très
haute bas ou alors standard bon moi
standard ça me va bien l'intervalle de
nettoyage des la vettes alors environ
toutes les 10 minutes moi ça me va bien
parce que c'est pas hyper sale chez moi
mais sur dans des moments où il y a un
peu plus de de saleté on peut lui dire
ben tu y vas plutôt toutes les 6 minutes
en profondeur ou alors tous les quart
d'heure bon une FA plus à vous de voir
le temps de séchage à l'air chaud comme
je vous le disais 2h 3h ou 4 He et puis
le vidage automatique soit automatique
soit intelligent automatique ça me va
bien il y a également le nettoyage
continu que je vous conseille de venir
cocher ce qui fait que s'il a besoin de
venir se recharger hop il va se
recharger directement et après il
reprendra le boulot là où il en était
vous avez également l'évitement des
obstacles 3D trou détect dont je vous ai
parlé et là vous avez deux options les
meilleures performances en exclusion de
zone ou alors la couverture de de
nettoyage plus large également le
programme de nettoyage donc là j'en ai
pas fait je peux venir en ajouter un on
va se dire par exemple que je veux qu'il
nettoie moi les matins à 9h30 chez moi
ça c'est un truc qui me va bien je
confirme je veux qu'il se répète le
lundi mardi mercredi jeudi vendredi ça
ça me va bien nettoyage automatique
alors je peux dire me g tout
automatiquement ou alors par zone ou
alors je peux venir personnaliser créer
un scénario pour moi automatique ça me
va très très très bien donc ça
j'enregistre tous les jours à 9h30 et
après ça me suffit pas parce qu'
également le weekend alors moi je vais
lui dire le samedi je veux que tu
viennes à 14 14h30 c'est un créneau qui
me va bien et ça je veux que tu me le
répètes tous les samedis et le dimanche
on va rien faire parce qu'on a envie
d'être peénard et puis la langue
français bien évidemment il y a encore
plus de paramètres avec votre assistant
vocal iico dont je vous parlais alors là
hop on vient l'activer comme ça vous
aurez qu'à dire ok iiko et vous lui
direz commencer le nettoyage arrêter la
tâche passer au mode standard les
produits consommables ont-ils expiré et
il y a plein plein de commandes donc
vous voyez ça qui est vachement
intéressant c'est que avec iico vous
pourrez en faire toujours plus que ce
que vous pourrez faire comme je vous
l'ai dit avec Amazon Alexa ou avec
Google assistant vous avez plein d'
exemple ça c'est vachement vachement
cool le journal de nettoyage les
accessoires et pièces voyez ce qu'il
faut venir changer et à quel moment mode
ne pas déranger B si vous voulez pas
être embêté là il vous a cartographié
votre maison en trois dimensions ça
c'est aussi vachement bien vous pouvez
venir personnaliser lui dire ben tiens
par exemple je veux que là tu viennes me
faire que ce coin là voilà là ça tac tu
viens me nettoyer j'ai renversé quelque
chose j'ai cassé un truc PAF tu va vous
pouvez également choisir la version don
vous allez venir afficher votre carte 2D
3D pourquoi pas quand vous allez sur le
côté vous avez un nettoyage personnalisé
donc là regardez je peux venir choisir
pour le nettoyage quotidien tu passes
par là et ça quand même qui est plutôt
pas mal c'est parce que je peux lui
indiquer regardez par exemple cette
pièce là tu vas passer une fois deux
fois la puissance d'aspiration ça sera
ça comme ça je peux créer des scénarios
je peux venir sélectionner des meubles
aussi si je veux choisir le type de mode
d'aspiration que je veux au quotidien
nettoyage quotidien nettoyage en
profondeur je peux venir totalement
créer des scénarios une fois de plus ça
c'est quand même super cool pensez donc
à venir vous équiper dans les meilleures
conditions avec des superers aSPIRATEURS
ROBOT décovax le dibot T20 omni et le
dbot t20e omni je vous le dis une fois
de plus la différence entre ces deux
modèles c'est que bien évid évidemment
le dbot T20 omni sera plus cher pourquoi
parce qu'il vous permet de venir
nettoyer avec votre serpillère à chaud à
55° c'est beaucoup mieux pour toutes les
tâes grasses et également pour les
odeurs tandis que le dbot t20e omni sera
également très bon propose toutes les
options qu'on trouve sur le dbot T20
omni sauf bien évidemment le nettoyage à
chaud le dbot T20 omni qui coûte
normalement 1099 € et bien ici eovax
vous fait 27 % de remise du 17 au 27
novembre 2023 pendant Black Friday et ça
vous le sort à 799 € c'est quand même
vachement en canon tandis que votre
dibot T20 e omni qui coûte 799 € et bien
du 13 au 27 novembre 2023 ecovax vous
fait une remise de 19 % et ça vous le
tombe à 649 €. c'est le meilleur moment
pour venir acheter vos appareils
électroniques votre électroménager vos
robots nettoyant pour la maison pensez
vraiment donc à bien vous équiper avec
les nouveaux aspirateurs descovax dbot
T20 omni dbx t20e omni une fois de plus
tous les liens sont présents juste en
bas dans la description et bien
puisqu'on parle ici d'assistant
intelligent avec de l'intelligence
artificielle je vous invite à venir voir
cette vidéo qui vous présente les U
meilleurs Z qui vont radicalement
changer votre vie vous m'en direz des
nouvelles